well on the mount for the seattle
mariners a guy who has given the angels
fits over the years 29 year old
left-hander marco gonzalez most recently
saturday in anaheim's seven innings of
one run baseball as he pitched the emps
to a 5-1 win a 1-2 pitch swagging up
this struck him out what a start
i think the mariners have the right guy
in the mountain and marco gonzalez
hanging up towards the gap and there's
kelnick for the out the one two to
goslin swing and a fly ball to the
shallow center field celtic racing and
he's there leaps up and he makes the
catch and that's gonna retire the side
and what a start for marco gonzalez on
the mount for the angels making his
final appearance of 2021 it's jose
suarez a 23-year-old left-hander last
pitched against these mariners on friday
at home
and went five innings that night allowed
four earned runs and crawford's hit with
the full count pitch that's how seattle
gets its lead off hitter aboard
france with a ground ball to third
mayfield of fletcher for one and the
angels double them off and the angels
turn it around the diamond and just like
that two outs no one on
and hannigan rolls it out to shortstop
that's fletcher on the other side of the
bag and the shift a couple of ground
balls make for a breezy start to the
night for jose suarez kyle seeger leads
things off in the mariners half of the
second
chummed on it
a swing and a miss first strike out of
the game for suarez the next 3-2 got him
on back-to-back curve balls what a
terrific plate appearance that was for
jose suarez how about that down in a
curveball followed by a backdoor
curveball on it to the touro
up the middle base hit first one of the
night for the mariners comes with two
outs here in the second and it brings up
a hero from a couple of nights ago jared
kellnick
down the line
in full flight manny will wave him
here comes the throw he's
gonna be
in there
dropping the ball is suzuki jared kelvik
does it again
one nothing meredith and here we go
coming with two outs a couple of
strikeouts the solid base hit by toro
and celtic being aggressive
and the next delivery a good change up
and he gets
the batter more to chase it struck him
out so suarez ends up striking out the
side mariners have the one to nothing
lead 101 to luis renjifo and there's a
base hitting the left
first angel hit of the night
just a little bit low on that one and
the angels have a pair on down one to
nothing here in the third no one out and
marsh will be the next batter
a fastball hit out to left field more
back and he can't make the catch
wren heapho streaking around third to
score fletcher right behind him the
throws off line two to one angels
boy both third base coaches being
aggressive here tonight what a swing
for marsh good at bat and driving this
baseball fast ball away stayed with it
he tracked the breaker ball early in the
sequence and gets this one over dylan
moore's headed 376 sign driving in two
with a double
there it is roll it over there's one
and
guess what he needed jose suarez now
with a 2-1 lead here in the bottom of
the third inning there you go that's
going to work that will work little
squibber
base runner to start the mariners home
third j.p crawford
i see paris icy france the seattle first
baseman has just grounded into his
second double play of the game
just like you said jose you clear the
mind after a bad
decision there as far as an elevated
breaker ball you get a ground ball
double play
strikes him out on three pitches
good pitch there from suarez another
strikeout for him and the inning is over
go back to work on david fletcher
long run for hannigan but he's got it
there under control fair territory one
out big out
it's well stroked haniger long run he's
there good job
terrific jump mitch hannigan swinging a
ground ball into the shift down in
shallow right field here's toro he's got
it to throw to first and it's in time to
get ohtani and that's going to retire
the side
it'll be mike myers and company to take
the angels the rest of the way
there's a little chopper hit on the left
side that one is fielded there by
mayfield and he will throw out france
and that is the first out
[Applause]
got him to pop up a slider
mayfield yields to heaphouse for route
number two myers back in the count the
two and one
little chip shot in front of the plate
for suzuki and a one two three sixth
authored by mike myers and casey sadler
will take over for the mariners here he
has been invincible
nasty breaking ball right there for the
strikeout of jared walsh looking for the
put away and he does well done
back-to-back case
ground ball toro routine play throws him
out sadler 27 appearances without giving
up a run
tonight looking to put the ball in place
kate twice
fly ball right field got carrie got a
shot
and it is
dropped the ball terrance still on the
move digging from third man he's gonna
tell him to get down alina triple
luis terrains and americans have the
tying run at third base lt with his
second triple of the season that'll get
the fans on their feet
look at this little cutter it looked
like hits it the other way great try by
lagaris goes into his glove
and not able to hang on to it as he hits
the wall thought it had a chance to get
out of the ballpark and it looked like
he was going to make the catch the 3-2
pitch to toro
take it for ball four runners at the
corners for derek kellnick and that's
going to be it for mike myers on a
relief who goes one plus inning so here
is quijada 3-2
you got it couldn't lay off the high
fastball boy that is clearly ball four
and kelnick couldn't stay off it
tauren's at third toro at first with one
away got him back-to-back strikeouts
now two outs in the inning they're still
runners at first and third
[Applause]
and the lead off triple is left stranded
in the last of the seventh jihadi comes
in and boy did he ever slam the door
shut here in the bottom of the seventh
inning right now the mariners need a one
two three inning out of diego castillo
against three four five in the order
got him
three consecutive strikeouts by mariner
pitching one away in the ninth
swang and a miss folding big time that's
four consecutive strikeouts by mariner
pitcher
broken bat jp's got it where else throws
a little wide
not a surprise in this situation that
scott service goes to the lefty to get
this important out
desperately wants to keep this a one-run
game and that's it right to jp perfect
he's had a lot of one pitch innings very
nicely done here we go buckle up need a
couple
reisel iglesias he has been fantastic
this year 33 saves in his 63 appearances
in the corner
digging hard zigger going for two he's
gonna get there a lead off doubled by
the veteran's third baseman can't come
to meredith in the night
that's in play
seeger cannot advance and there's one
god
and this is popped up infield behind the
mound waiting for it is renjifo he makes
the catch and now two are gone here in
the bottom of nine
late start by rojas he's there and the
angels win it by the count of two to one
they're running out of time that's a
costly loss that's one that they're
going to think about
you